all right got any vacation plans this
summer clark county credit union has the
financial tools you need for travel
rocky checked in with them for details
welcome back craig
hello good to see you good to see you
too now it is getting hot outside
summer is approaching we're getting
ready to plan our vacations and
staycations
and clark county credit union is here to
help us right yes that's correct
one of the greatest tools we have for
whether you're doing a staycation or
vacation or just going out and about
as our mobile banking app with that you
can access your funds 24
7 you can transfer funds from one
account to another instantly
one of the greatest features is that you
can set up automatic account alerts
and those are customized so where this
comes in handy is when you're on
vacation you can get involved in impulse
buying
and you can end up spending more than
you wanted to you can have your account
alert you when your balance is hit a
certain amount so that's really good
about that we also have a tool called
the personal financial management tool
on our online banking
through that you can track where you're
spending and you that helps you to keep
on budget
what other kind of benefits do you guys
have for people to take advantage of
for the summer time yes this is a great
advantage benefit for
vacations or at any time it's called our
bonus checking account
and this is good whether you're doing a
staycation or vacation as well
because it works in any zip code so you
type in the zip code where you're going
to be and you'll see discounts on movie
theaters restaurants
retail shopping rental cars so you get
all these discounts and all these
perks are free once you sign up for
bonus checking and of course many people
prefer to use credit cards while they
travel do you guys have any special
credit products that we should use
yes this works whether you're using your
credit card or your debit card we have
bonus reward points for both which makes
it unique because we're doing it for
both credit and debit
and when you're uh shopping right now
through
july 30th there's a amazon promotion
where you get three times the bonus
points
so if right now you want to shop and
stock up for your summer supplies for
your vacation
never it's never been a better time to
use your clark county credit card
than right now and get those three times
bonus points wow that i like the sound
of that too
and of course you know there are some
people who aren't quite ready
to travel just yet so is there a future
travel plan
or savings plan that you guys provide
yes we have what's called a vacation
club account
and with that it's an automatic savings
account that you have to put like ten
dollars a month minimum in
but i think it'd be great if you set it
up through your direct deposit because
then you're saving automatically you
just decide how much every payday
you want to put into the vacation club
account and this is a separate account
from your normal savings and your normal
checking
so it just builds up like in the
background you don't even look at it
just let it build up over time
and then on may 15th those funds are
transferred to your
checking account so that you'll have it
for vacation and we also have a
christmas club account that works the
same way you can set it up with
automatic uh
payments to go right into it let it
build up over time and we have a
promotion going right now
through the end of june if you sign up
for a vacation club account
or a christmas club account you'll be
entered in to win an additional 250
dollars
that will go into your account you just
have to sign up before the end of june
give clark county credit union a call at
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org they have a special offer you
can open any club savings account from
now through june 30th
to enter for an additional 250
disbursement at maturity date mercedes